[Musique]
et après de câbles
on a mais on avait remis les caméras
c'est quand même très très utile un
poids propre d'édition ravi de vous
retrouver pour tous pas mon poste et le
vendredi de camplong j'ai la chance de
remplacer série et vous allez voir que
je fais je fais un franc succès dans l
on est dans le hall
il ya une ambiance de fou la regarde et
voilà ils sont trois voila voila c voilà
c'est fait merci merci et alors plus de
monde encore plus drôle encore tout à
l'heure on a préparé un peu l'émission
et notre assistant après me demander en
voyant le plan de table où j'étais assis
autour de la table ce qu'il voyait pas
forcément puisque puisque forcément je
suis censé dali mais voilà tout ça pour
vous dire que suis très heureux d'être
là on va c'est une belle émission en
sont un bel invités on a 7 al maliki
sera là qui parlera de wonder woman
certains acteurs français qui jouent
beaucoup en amérique et puis on a la
joyeuse troupe qui sont juste derrière
à ces absences on l'a remis en marche se
bat ça m'arrivait nous avons la joyeuse
troupe
c'est bon on peut reculer on a assez de
câbles ou rester alors qu'ils revenaient
vers des mois donc la jeunesse bandes
qui est derrière cette porte qui va
jouer avec nous à toc toc toc puisque on
va parler de wonder woman on va deviner
qui se cache dans la porte et surtout
quelle chanson ils ont choisi jeudi
toc toc toc qui est là qui est là voilà
ils n'ont pas encore là qui est là et
qui est qui merci parce qu'il met de
nouveau vous êtes là ou pas allez allez
on va commencer avec le premier est la
flash qui sa fraîche mitsou de moules
romy nouvelle
l'émission l'émission n'a pas très bien
commencé
n'avez-vous support suis pas très bon
deuxième
toc toc et là tu es là tu es d'un 2010
alors c'était était censé être daredevil
c'est le mec qui est toute en rouge
avait voilà c'est avoir de costume c'est
vrai c'est très joli faisait dire à ces
bleus quand même couleur chez triumph un
an la finale c'est beau ranger sans
merci maxiq telle à dakar et la robine
mais robin qui robin robin deux dirigent
jovi jobijoba
élégant robin le batman et robin basso
ita 6 q des mois batman et robin
exactement où pensez à qui bat robin
hood robin des bois par les banques non
c'est par l'anglais mais ces deux sur
les super-héros là bas des bois et d'un
super pouvoir
à l'énoncé reset d'autres héros et c'est
bon ensuite t'as sheila et hulk c'est
hulk c'est hulk ça j'ai hâte de huawei
hussein ligne
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo bravo
c'était évidemment jean noir le
producteur de before est hélas bien
chaud nordine il alors dit ah non c'est
cécilia rachète séquence ah non il faut
jouer de louis ii remercie vraiment
cessé les trucs j'ai pas fini encore au
bar on m'a encore c'est meilleur pour la
fin ok tu es bon stock à mon dieu qui
est là c'est green lantern
[Rires]
belle-isle-en-terre green lantern rouler
on vend des landes de pierres autour
bella pour les vivants
on ne connaît pas
la mesa crachant ses filiales est donc
c'était green lantern
en fait on n'avait pas du tout le budget
pour vous costumer en fait il faut il
faut tout imaginer en fait super héroïne
moderne suivant qui est là captain
america
captain america captain qui capte l
amérique
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà
je ne sais pas
et et attendait et c'est pas fini le
plus grave c'est que si le pire arrive
c'est ça alors qu'ea les y suivent en
attaque
cliquez là vas y vas rire wolverine
golfeurs qui vivez vous ressembler un
peu à l'aune de romane et un petit côté
carter et même d'un carter mais en plus
jeunes bien sûr ces paquets la jalade à
60 au nom donc ça me donne une idée j'ai
utilisées c'est bien mais quand j'ai des
idées généralement elles sont bonnes je
ne serais pas là toujours pas toujours
merci emilie merci pour suivre cette
séquence mémorable et là bas qui est là
batman batman qui rate manson ont crevé
je frôle la la
là
oui ça promet avec les filles et les
garçons
j'ai bien remarqué cette chanson de
bécaud pour batman
ouais c'est vachement bien ça
réactualise vrai que j'ai passé sur ce
passé bécaud ouais alors attendez assez
abbaoui la machine et on a gardé
meilleur pour la fin sinon l'épisode le
banc
généralement on est ou encore eva fille
on est haut en chansons on est haut en
rythme on est haut en vannes on se
parlait jamais déçu alors bas sera
frappée c'est qui c'est superman super
quoi superman superman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
en
ouais
il faut que je m'y remette
wen mais il ya des il ya des très beaux
restes j'ai été bluffé par la souplesse
ouais je vous parle pas de l'intérieur
parce que comment comment pour comment
peut-on être soupe de l'intérieur espère
expliquez moi tous ses muscles chez un
individu d'entrée muscle a compris le
périnée on va on va dépêcher d'aller sur
le sur le bateau bong donc aujourd'hui
super héros qui dit super héros 10 10
j'ai un petit jeu ça va être long
l'émission ça va tourner alors faire un
petit jeu je vais vous donner des
indices soient des indices en beau
emprunt soit audio la baguette dite mal
si vous reconnaissez ce à quoi je fais
allusion
vous allez foncé dans la malle il veut
me ramener l'accessoire y afférents ok
on est présent ces appareils si je vous
dis par exemple acquis à partir cette
voiture que je n'ai pas dans la main par
exemple mais qui est qui mais qui est là
voilà un exemple
c'est un exemple
c'est un exemple n'ya pas y'a pas on
regarde on se cale à la voilà en tout
cas voilà alors alors c'est un exemple
là il aurait fallu me ramener un masque
de ce batman cause les que voulait pas
trouvé c'est vraiment nul
il tue pas j'ai trouvé c'est quoi ça
dans heroes jours résa au niveau des
seconds s'est pressé vous parfois qu'une
mini caméra au début d'émission n'arrête
ans et c'est vraiment alors camembert
qui doivent faire tu pues attention
attention attention écouter cette
musique
[Musique]
et sony vont se blesser
downey jr qui bien qu est ce que c est
qu musique en boîte à pizza j'ai ramené
une boîte à pizza pour quoi faire pour
vous ramener une voiture j'ai l'habitude
les pizzas je les livre tout exprès je
vous demande de vous ramener l'objectif
correspond à la musique on a entendu moi
je suis habituée aux vidéos alors
c'était bon fine et le masque ouais mais
c'est faux les mais je m'en fous aller à
tokyo
voilà voilà comme ça voilà comme ça
comme ça j'aurais pu voter allez-y
alors maxime ça ne jouais pas ça l'accès
la mission vous pouvez vous rendre
il fera un excellent petit les éliminer
je vais dîner caroline du nord pour des
raisons sert qu'à regarder vers l'est
puis de l'avoir avec nous a lésés
mettez vos derrière ensuite
attention voici une question mais gilles
j'ai un chemin plus long à parcourir
je mange tout le temps
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est bon alors attendez que mange tout
le temps étant puni déjà de la pizza il
faut donc la manger bio
bizarre voilà donc gilles petit bout qui
se fait vous dînez christophe christophe
serieys remercie en ascension nous
attend mais attention on fera quoi
attention ça décoiffe physique mais
musique
[Musique]
je les vois là
thébaux d'avoir pour le mais on met nos
masques oui bah bien je vais l'aider
nous là bas ça fait mal à les attentions
alors qu'ils s'étaient vus éliminer mais
dévié et l'éliminer qui maximiseront
travers notre attention
comment s'appelle la meilleur ennemi de
batman
qu'est ce qui te rend métier
les revenus et revenir bien revenez
mettez le mettez le mettez le donc il
fallait évidemment sauver cap-aux-meules
bien jouer vous éliminer deux personnes
deux personnes au dessus de personnes
assez dur de perdre 12 février moi même
j'ai la gamme power ce soir donc les
deux mecs c'est le mec j'ai gardé est
damien je t'envoie est ce qu est ce qu
on pouvait m'éliminer j'analyse la
regarde et on les garde fous et
m'éliminer
c'est donc attention celui qui gagne
celui ci au final celui qui gagne une
celle qui gagne bah oui elle est dedans
allez-y celles qui gagnent maintenant
désigne les personnes qui passera la
soirée déguisée en wonder woman a mis
tous les cas non parmi tous les
chroniqueurs
absolument oui alors qu'est super héros
se cache derrière
bruce banner
je te laisse aller à m'étais bien joué
alors des bois a laissé gagner agathe
qui en slovaquie en roumanie qui emmène
doruma de quoi ceux-ci
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas fait on a on se retrouve en
instaurant pour tous à mon poste avec
said taghmaoui et mon camarade leur
envoyer que je ne vous ai pas